على عكس ما يتمنى شعبيه تاريخي ادنى
مستوياتها بعد فيضان المقابلات والمذكرات
التي طرحت رسميا
في مجلس النواب الاردني ولاول مره في
التاريخ روبوت محامي ايضا يستعد للمرافعه
امام قاضي الشهر المقبل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ايه ده مشاهدينا في فيديو منتشر اله كم
يوم في من الصوت التواصل في مصر عامل حاله
من الاشتياق والحزن لكن القصه انتهت اليوم
نهايه سعيده الحمد لله خليني بالاول
اذكركم بالمقطع واللي ما شافوا اصلا عشان
يشوفوا
وحياه ربنا
والله العظيم يا ابني اقسم لك بالله
العظيم
وحياه النبي
حلفتك بالله عليك
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
والله العظيم ما بهدلت حاجه والله احب على
راسك
[موسيقى]
الفيديو اللي شفته مشاهدينا كان في
بورسعيد واللي ظاهر في رجل مسن بيعمل في
جمع البلاستيك من النفايات وهذا هو مصدر
رزقه لكن في شخص اتضح بعدين انه موظف رسمي
صادر العربي منه وعملوا مثل ما شفته
بطريقه اعتبرها كثار موهينا وموسيقى
وبعدين انتشار الفيديو وتصدر هاشتاج عامل
نظافه بورسعيد حقك علينا ترن بعد ما تصدر
طبعا هذا الهاشتاج تحركت السلطات الرسميه
رئيس هايبر سعيد استدعى العامل واعتذر له
عمه بدر منه واكد اي حاله الموظف لتحقيق
وكمان عرض عليه وظيفه للعمل في الحي لكسب
لقناه عائشه
اذا مشاهدينا صار موضوع يومي معنا خلاص
طبعا الامير هاري واللي عم يعملوا او
بالاصح الي بفجره من تصريحات عن العائله
المالكه في سلسله مقابلات هو اصلا عم يروج
فيها لملك مذكرات مليانه فضايحري من وقت
حلقه امبارح لليوم في مقابلات وتفاصيل
جديده طلعت هذا غير انه اليوم طرح رسميا
الكتاب حول العالم لتفكير بس من اول يوم
كان مقرر للمذكرات انها تطرح في 10 يناير
لكنها نزلت بكير كم يوم في اسبانيا تحديدا
خلينا مشاهدينا نختصر سريعا سواء ابرز
الجدل اللي اجى في الكتاب والمقابلات هذه
بدايه قال انه العيله المالكه بتتعامل مع
الصحافه الصفراء اللي وصفها بالشيطان
لتحسين صورتهم على حساب الاخرين هو كمان
قال انه الملك ترولز بيغار من زوجته
وزوجته
وانه بيسرقوا او بيخاف من انه يسرقوا منه
الاضواء هذه كمان في هذه المذكرات وهاي
المؤابلات الناريه
يعني اخوه وزوجه اخوه انه ما كانوا مرحبين
بانضمام ماجن وحكموا عليها بالصوره
النمطيه
حريق كمان انه او اتحدث بشكل مستب ايضا عن
غيره بينه وبين اخوه ووصفه بعده اللدود
وروى تفاصيل عن خناقه اخوه او خناقه
خلالها اخوه ضربه في عام 2019 وكانت كل
الخناقه بسبب
نشر ايضا هو نشر مضمون رسائل نصيه ما بين
وكاثر بسبب فستان الاميره تشارليت
هاي طبعا خنقت مجنن تكلمت عنها لاول مره
في مقابله اوبرا وقالت انه بسببها قعدت
تبكي على الارض حكى الامير هاري كمان عن
توسله هو واخوه لوالد الملكرز انه ما
يتزوج كامله ووصف كامله بالشريره بالخطيره
زي ما انتم شايفين مشاهدينا تصريحات ناريه
كثير همم من ضمنها ايضا حكى عن وفاه
والدته وتعامل ابوه معه وقتها وعندها
منجمه لحتى يحاول يتواصل مع امه في قبرها
والمقارنه المستمره ما بين امه
حكى ايضا عن قتله 25 مسلح من طالبان في
افغانستان وهو في سلاح الجو البريطاني همم
وكيف انه هذا الموضوع او على الاقل خدمته
في افغانستان عددته على تخطي صدمه وفاه ام
ايضا الامير هريره والتفاصيل عن فقدان
عذريته وهو في عمر 17 سنه مع امراه تكبره
في العمر في حق الخلف بار وحكى عن تعطيل
المخدرات والحشيش في شبابه قال كمان انه
هو ما راح يرجع ولا بريطانيا ابدا
طبعا بعد كل هذا قال انه بيرغب في
المصالحه مع ابوه اخوه بس هم اللي ما بدهم
ولا ابدوا اي استعداد لهذا الموضوع الامير
هاري من يوم ما ترك العائله المالكه
مشاهدينا هو وزوجته من بعدها بعدها طبعا
مقابله اوبرا الشهيره لكلنا طلعنا عليها
وسلسله كمان التصريحات اللي طلعت منه ضد
العائله المالكه بعدها من وقتها يعني اكثر
من الناس ضده لانه في نفس الوقت كان في
شريحه كبيره متعاطفه معه معها ايضا يعني
مع زوجته وشايفين انه اللي عملوه مبرر
ومفهوم خاصه في امريكا على ما يبدو هناك
في تعاطفه كبيره الامريكان سواء مواطنين
او حتى اعلان كانوا بنسبه كبيره
ومتعاطفينها في صفحهم لكن الملاحظ الان
انه من بعد هذه المذكرات والسلسله
المقابلات الاخيره الوضع تغير وسائل اعلام
امريكيه بدات تنقلب عليهم على فكره مش بس
وسائل الاعلام ولكن شريحه كبيره من
المواطنين من حول العالم من ما كانوا
متعاطفين مع هاري وماجن وحابينهم بعد كل
الفضائح المنشوره هلا قلبوا عليهم وشايفين
اللي عم بيصير مش طبيعي وكثير زاد عن حدهم
على كل حال احنا راح نحكي فيه كل هذه
النقاط مع ابزال
مسؤوله سياسات في الجمعيه الملكيه
البريطانيه والمعلق السياسي هو معنى العام
المنظر اهلا بك استاذ افال راح ابلش معك
برؤيتك كيف بتنظر لا همم المذكرات الامير
هاري لكل التصريحات الناريه اللي انحكت في
المقابلات الاخيره اللي عملها طبعا كلها
كانت لترويش
بكره الجزيره
من القلق وقد فاجئت الكثيرين
وقد صدمت الكثيرين
الذين دعموه
البريطانيين
الاسره الملكه وفي المؤسسات البريطانيه
الكثيرين في المملكه المتحده هؤلاء يرون
الان بانه يستخدم هذا الكتاب هذه المذكرات
لتحقيق مكاسب ماليه
لزياده شعبيه
المال اذا الناس يرون الان الحقيقه وراء
كل ذلك
بالفعل شعبيه الامير هاري وماجن انخفضت
بشكل كبير زي ما هو يعني بلشنا نشوف او
لانه زادت الانتقادات على هيئه تصريحات
الناريه اللي عملها كل هذه الفضائح اللي
كشف عنها هل داخل بريطانيا ينخفضت عين
نسبه خصوصا همم في همم يعني بين الشباب
اللي كانوا بشكل عام داعمين هارون
همم
نظرائي كلهم يتفقون على انه حتى
الحقيقه يمكن
مختلف همم
اقل وهناك من يشعر بالحرج
لا يمكن ان يدعمه ابدا
طيب ماذا بالنسبه للولايات المتحده يعني
في امريكا العائله الملكه البريطانيه يعني
هو موضوع اهتمام كبير من قبل عامه الشعب
وحتى الفنانين والسياسيين وغيره هل ايضا
من لاحظ بانه حتى عام 2005
في الولايات المتحده اللي هي بتحضنهم هلا
دهست كيك
عندما
المقابله مع اوبرا وينفري يعتقد الزوج ان
الشعبيتهما سوف تزداد وان الناس سوف يرون
الحقيقه خلف الاسره الملكه ومحدث حتى هو
ان حتى الامريكيين الذين يحترمون كثيرا
الاسره الملكه
البريطانيه
من القصص المزيفه في المقابله
خاصه وانهما
ذهاب الى امريكا
الى اين سيذهبان الان
يعني قبل ما ننهي ايضا ودتا اسالك عن
شعبيه ال- ال- الملك تشارلز وايضا الامير
ويليام بعد هذه التصريحات التي ادلى بها
هاري هل تاثرت باي شكل من الاشكال ام
بالعكس هناك دعم اكبر خصوصا في المملكه
المتحده
التي تم جمعها بسبب المقابلات فان
الاحصاءات اظهرت بان الشعبيه
شعبيه
بالكثير من الشعبيه وكانت ذلك مفاجاه
للكثيرين في المملكه المتحده وهذا ينطبقه
شعبيته لم تتاثر وهو يحفظ
كثير اعتقد ان صدركوا ان الملك او الاميره
ويليام يقومان
بواجباتهما بطريقه تحت بالكثير من
الاحترام طيب
هل جنه الامير هاري خصوصا انه بنتي اد
العائله المالكه في بعض الشغلات مثل انهم
بيتعاملوا مع الشيطان يعني الصحافه
الصفراء وعم بعطي يعني
كل الاخبار هاي اللي عم بحكي فيها للصحه
في الصفراء على طبق بنهاب الانف
الجمله هو انها يقوم
باطعام
الحيوان
وهو الان يوفر هذه المعلومات وبالتالي هذه
سوف ينعكس عليه واعتقد نعم الامير هاري
اخطا كثيرا في ما قام به وهو يحرج نفسه
اكثر من اي شخص اخر
شكرا جزيلا لك افزال بربس مسؤوله سياسات
في الجمعيه الملكيه البريطانيه والمعلق
السياسي كان معنا من لندن
في مقطع فيديو من جلسه البرلمان الاردني
يمكن يكون مر على كثير منكم اللي في مقطع
من جلسه كانت من كم يوم ووقتها تشرت
بالاردن بشكل كبير وهلا انتشرت عربيا كمان
خصوصا على واتساب ويعني بصراحه مفهوم لما
نسمع انه لما نسمع اسم شكسبير بيتنادى
عليه تحت قبه البرلمان الاردني اكيد الكل
راح يستغرب شويه خلينا نشوف ههه
[موسيقى]
ههه مثل ما سمعته المشاهدين عشان كثير كان
حاضر تحت قبه البرلمان حاضر الجلسه ومش بس
مش بس شكسبير ولكن كمان بايضه عموما
المقطع تمت دوله بشكل واسع بصراحه كان
ماده للسخريه والضحك كثار علقوا عليه انه
الكوميديا ما وقفت عند شكسبير بس
فبقيه المقطع ما كان نوع مختلف خلينا نشوف
هاي الستروره شو حكت 3 بالضبط
بالعربي اتفضل بدنا نشرح لك رد الاخت
لوراء يعني تفضل اكيد خلصت انا بدناش نحكي
خلاص طيب شكرا
في ركاب طائره روسيه عاشوا كابوس الحقيقه
ولحظات من الرعب ما بينحسوا عليها ابدا
يمكن الواحد لو كان مكانهم انا كان حرفيا
يمكن متت من الخوف بصراحه الرعب اللي صار
هو انه الطياره صغيره من طراز سته وعشرين
باب هالخلفين فتح وهم في محلقين في الجو
الطياره طبعا تعرضت لمشكله فنيه
فتح الباب واحد من الركاب مش عارفه بصراحه
كيف سيطر اداري يسيطر على اعصابه على حاله
وصور ووثق اللي صار بالضبط
عن جد الله يعينهم على اللحظات الصعبه انا
ما بعرف لو انا كنت مكانهم شو كان ممكن
اعمل الباب فتح على كل حال وبلشت اغراض
الركاب تطير هذا غير طبعا البرد يعني اصلا
الجو تخيلوا على ارتفاع عالي بيكون تحت
الصفر فتخيلوا انه هن مقلعين من منطقه
سايبيريا للحراره فيها على الارض مش بالجو
يمكن ناقص 44 او همم 44 تحت الصفر فكيف
تخيلوا في الجو عموما لحسن الحظ الطاقه من
عرف يرجع الضغط في الطياره طبيعي
ولفت ورجعت وهبطت بسلام والركاب ال 25
الحمد لله اللهم لهم طياره مثل ما قلنا هي
طياره روسيه فمين اللي حب يستغل الموقف
وما يمراها اوكرانيا طبعا مستشار لوزير
الشؤون الداخليه الاوكرانيا المسؤول نشر
الفيديو حكى اللي صار وعلق بالاخر وكتب هل
نغير اسم الرولات الروسي ونسميه الطائره
الروسيه
طبعا اللي ما بعرف الرولات الروسي هي لعبه
حظ مميته معروفه من قرود وهي ببساطه انه
ينحط طلقه واحده في
الفرد او في بيت الطلقات باي فرد وبالتالي
بعد هيك بينطخ على شخص تطلع الطلقه ما
بتطلع الطلقه عاد
مشاهدينا في شباب امريكي
توني
[موسيقى]
يعني مثل ما شفته مشاهدينا بالفيديو خلال
دقائق بس الشرطه صارت عند الشاب لانها
فكرت انه في جريمه وانه في اثنين انقتلوا
الشب سمع صوت كلبه وطلع يركض لا الشرطه
رفع ايده طبعا وما كان فاهم شو عم بيصير
صارت الشرطه تسالوا ووجهت مسدساتها عليه
وفاتت فتشت البيت كمان زاويه زاويه واللي
نشر القصه هو صاحبه اللي قال انه الشاب
قعد يرجف اربع ساعات يا حرام من الخوف
وعموما القصه خلصت
والشرطه همم روحت وبعد ما اقتنعت انه ما
في جريمه ولا شيء ونصيحه مني لما بدكم
تلعبوا هيك العاب خلوا تليفونكم بعيد
تطورات تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي عم تظهر
البشريه يوم بعد يوم والجديد بخبرنا عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو روبوت محامي بيستعد
دخول المحاكم لاول مره في التاريخ متى
الشهر المقبل
فاعلن الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه دونات عن
عفوا عن روبوت هو الاول من نوعه رح يدخل
يدافع عن متهم في محكمه في فبراير وطريقه
عمله رح تكون عبر الهاتف الذكي في الروبوت
راح يستمع الى الاقوال والشهادات ومشتريات
المحاكمه عابر سماعه بلوتوث ومن بعدها راح
يصير ردود المناسبه ويدافع عن المدعي عليه
مش عارفه اذا بكون في حدا عم بلقنه واللي
هو من حاله وعماله درس قانوني يعني مش
عارفه على كل حال السبب الاساسي استغلال
التكنولوجيا هو تخفيفه كثير من الناس
احم عفوا اللي ما بيقدروا يتحملوا تكاليف
المحاماه العاليه وللفت في نهايه
تكنولوجيا انه في حال خساره المحامي
الروبوت الدعوه الدعوه او الشركه بتدفع اي
غرامات
وبتترتب هاي الغرامات يعني على المدعي
عليه وصلنا لختام هاي الحلقه مشاهدينا
اشكركم حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]